you would reference the movie thank you
for smoking um in at least one of your
videos forgive me I haven't seen it but
I want to make a point to see it and
I've heard from many people actually it
looked amazing yeah and there were so
many he's so charismatic in it you know
yeah exactly and how he said he has sort
of this BA and what was it what was his
exact same public relations okay Oh bien
I yes yeah right and he's the
guy that can talk the girl into anything
kind of thing yeah and so what what what
in that movie how would you break down
the text the subtext in the context and
how much do you think that relates to
the entertainment business in the sense
that they're trying to make it seem that
smoking is okay they're they're trying
to portray that it's actually okay that
see what I think is interesting I mean
ultimately that's what I love that movie
because it's a plum ik it's it's
presented as morally it's it's about
moral ambiguity you know it there's this
larger theme which is basically saying
like culture this is this is a really
complex breakdown it's a complex
movement I love it it's one of
my favorites but at its core it's it's
it's about this guy who's trying to sell
smoking but what he's really trying to
do I mean it's it's an exercise in
rhetoric but what he's really trying to
do is say I don't want people to
determine my life for me I want to take
control of my own life and I would get
to decide if I want throat cancer or not
which is why at the very end you're like
if my kid wants to smoke I'm gonna light
it up for him because it's not really
about him saying like it's okay to smoke
what he's really the whole story is this
journey of him facing these you know
largely it's one of the themes that's
really close to me which is large tribal
groups trying to impose their values on
individuals and his individuality coming
back and saying no you I'm gonna do
what I want to do and you're kind of a
villain for trying to impose that on
other people and I and it does it in
such a clever polemic way and smoking is
really just a pretext that gets us into
it because it's something that you know
most people largely condemn I don't
smoke and it's not it's not healthy but
at the same
who are you to decide that for other
people and that's what that movie is
asking about but from from a great
rhetorical position you know so would
you say in some sense there's themes in
terms of story the entertainment
industry and how we view what's
acceptable to watch I think like what
Rob Lowe plays the studio executive he's
like pitching upside yeah I think that's
definitely he's like he names to me like
yes how he sees the world is just yeah
what what you know blockbusters are sort
of I don't know I've been thinking about
like especially the entertainment
industry and like a lot of a lot of
people like especially on your channel
the interviews you guys are doing lots
of discussion about you know what are
the best rules for survival in the
entertainment industry and for me
there's a metaphor that just kind of
describes it simply which is that the
entertainment industry is like a harbor
and we have a constantly shifting tide
the water is going up and down and that
tide is the amount of tension that
people are willing to pay to things now
the industry does the best they can and
we're talking by industry specifically
we're talking about studios distribute
distributors production companies
they're trying to understand which way
the water is going where it's moving and
most of the time like you know as a
writer you're trying to swim in these
choppy seas because you're you you've
built your craft and you're trying to
dock in the harbor now the studios I
have these docks and they're through the
harbor right and because the water is
constantly shifting the best you can do
is make your craft is adaptable to
whatever the needs of the harbor are so
they're they're looking for whatever is
going to draw in the water as much as
possible this metaphor might break down
a little bit if we get too expensive
but um but the idea is basically
everybody has to adapt to the shifting
tide and the studio's especially they
have the most at stake so they're
looking for stories or writers crafts
persons that have built crafts that are
adaptable to the shifting tides and you
know there are some studios that have
built these massive mega harbors and
your little dinghy comes up and it's
just going to get beat up against the
water because it'll be swallowed up
because it because the waters changing
so much now especially with the changing
of like streaming and distribution
models are radically shifting and indie
film is shifting and you know if people
are making movies for less than a
million dollars the harbor is
dramatically different than it was five
years ago ten years ago so when it comes
to the industry all you're trying to do
is find your path in the best thing you
can do is focus on developing your
crafts as much as possible making as
adaptable as possible which is really
just the process of being able to delve
into your metaphors and really work on
being able to tell the stories that are
compelling to other people and that's
that's a no one has the right answer to
that we're all just figuring that out
you